hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be giving an
introduction a beginner's guide to buy
to let property investing maybe you've
considered buying a house and renting it
out but you're not sure what the pros
and the cons are versus other things
like cryptocurrencies business or maybe
buying your own house to live in so in
this video i'm going to outline the good
and the bad the pros and the cons of buy
select property investing i'm going to
be using my experience to talk about the
due diligence that you need to do before
you buy a property the types of
mortgages that you're going to need
where the best areas are in the uk in
2022 and also what the next steps are if
you do decide to buy a property as a buy
to let how do you find it where do you
go who do you talk to and what are the
next steps so if you enjoy my content do
me a favor and hit the like button and
that would really help me out a lot so
firstly by tonight investing is it good
is it bad there's a lot of talk about
buy to let being dead by till it being
hard and i don't agree with that because
i remember people saying that 10 years
ago when i first started building my buy
to let portfolio everybody always
complains and the reason i think they
complain is because they haven't got the
funds they haven't got the money to buy
a property and to rent it out but
actually if you have got the money i
think it's a great investment let me
explain why if you put say 20 000 pounds
into the stock market
let's say on average the stock market
trends up and it goes up by 10 per annum
which is about standard and after 10
years your your money has doubled that
would be a really good investment you'd
be really happy with that i imagine
you've doubled your money in 10 years
but the property market historically
also doubles
on average every 10 years i mean
certainly if you look over the last
two years it's gone up by 10 per annum
if you look at the last 10 years the
last 20 years that's 50 100 years
properties double in value every 10
years generally speaking so if you put
20 000 pounds down in a stock and it
doubles after 10 years you've doubled
your money but if you put 20 000 pounds
down on a buy to let house with a buy to
let mortgage and rent it out
not only are you going to be getting an
income from that property every single
month
but if that property doubles in value
you've not just doubled your money have
you because the twenty thousand pounds
was the deposit
if the house was a one hundred thousand
pound house and you put down 20 grand
the house doubles in value not the
deposit so your 20 grand
has now become a 200 000 pound house so
you've effectively not just doubled your
money but you've made a hundred thousand
pounds profit on 20 grand we call that
leverage and the great thing about
property is that you can do this you
can't do this with bitcoin you can't do
this with the stock market you can't do
this with gold and silver you can't
borrow money from the banks to buy gold
you can't borrow money from the banks to
buy stocks because
they're too volatile the banks would
consider it too high risk but property
is a very safe investment it's a very
unvolatile investment which gives you
capital appreciation and rent and that's
why people that make a lot of money
invest it into property ninety percent
of the time so i personally think that
buy to let investing is a very good
investment it's very safe sure you can
make more fast money doing business or
rent to rent or but i think buy-to-let
is a very good safe investment and it's
done me very very well so
where should you buy buy-to-properties
i think it's a myth to say that you have
to buy where you live people that say
they have to buy where they live oh i
want to buy half an hour from my house
i'll say why and they'll say because if
there's a problem i'll be able to step
in
that's a terrible plan a because you
know why there will be a problem and
then you will have to step in and that's
not financial freedom that's called a
rope around your neck that's called a
financial burden that's a headache so
what i would advise if you're looking at
buying today investing is to find an
area that actually works well people
moan oh boy to that doesn't work because
it might not work very well where they
live but actually find somewhere that it
does work
and then put a management team in place
typically a management company for
biotech properties will charge 10 of the
rent so if the rent's a thousand pounds
a month they'll take 100 pounds and then
they'll give you the 900 pounds people
say oh no i want to make more money i
want to make the 4 000 but then you're
going to have to manage it you're going
to have to find and vet the tenants
you're going gonna have to collect the
rent you're gonna if there's any
maintenance you're gonna have to deal
with the maintenance man the letting
agent there are companies out there in
pretty much every single city across the
uk where companies will offer a
completely hands-off management
experience for landlords and investors
and they on average charge 10 of the
rent so what i would say is find an area
whereby
you can make good returns what do i mean
by that
this is really really interesting and
you need to know this if you're wanting
to invest in buy-to-let property and
that is this that there is no direct
correlation
between house prices
and market rents
what do i mean by this i mean if you've
got an area whereby the house prices are
a million pounds okay the million pounds
or the average houses are a million
pounds they're saying i don't know some
nice part of york or something
well the rents might be
a thousand pounds
but if you then find another area where
the house prices are a tenth of the
price
they're not a million pounds a hundred
grand
the rents will not be a tenth of the
price the rents won't be a hundred
pounds
so there's no direct correlation between
house prices and rents which is why i
believe if you're going to be a buy to
let investor you should buy low
and rent high
this i'm going to give you a poem right
now this poem pretty much sums up
everything i know about biotech
investing and it goes like this buy low
rent high with a property manager
nearby
that pretty much sums up buy to let
property investing so find areas where
you can buy houses cheap
rent them for as high as you can with a
management company so that it can be
completely systemized so where do you
find these types of houses what areas
exist well i've bought houses in places
like middlesbrough on the outskirts of
manchester hall block switch i've built
up a lot of my portfolio in block switch
some of the houses that i bought in
blocks which were like 65 grand they've
now doubled in value i've had the same
tenants in there for over a decade so
i don't live there i live in
buckinghamshire if i'm on holiday i'm
not worried thinking what happens if
there's a problem why because my
management company are taking care of
everything so if you're looking at a
property to buy these are the things you
need to do number one you need to look
at the epc certificate online and check
that the energy performance certificate
is at least a d they're changing the
rules and they're saying that it needs
to be a c by 2025. what this means is
the house needs to be energy efficient
so if the the windows are single glazed
the walls aren't insulated then it's
probably going to be a bad energy
performance house which is going to mean
your bills are expensive
the tenants are going to be unhappy and
you're going to have to make
improvements to the house you can check
this on if you just google epc
certificate postcode it will come up
with the council website you can search
the address and you can find out what
the epc is you can also find on the ebc
other interesting information like how
big the house is how many square footage
the house is if you know how big the
house is because it's on the epc you can
then go on right move look at sold house
prices look at all the houses that sold
in the street find out how much they
sold for find out how big they were and
then you can work out the value of the
house before you offer on it and you can
use this as negotiation power when
offering on a property number two
make sure you get a server on the house
before you buy it you want an
independent building survey on the house
before you buy it really really really
really important number three you want
to make sure that the management company
is a good management company check their
reviews build rapport with them make
sure that the management company is good
number four
don't buy the first house that you see
be prepared to walk away view lots of
houses be prepared to walk away and work
out the return on investment return on
investment is how much cash am i putting
in
deposit stamp duty legal fees let's say
50 grand great
how much cash am i getting back
the rent
minus the mortgage payments the
maintenance the voids the management how
much profit am i expected to be making
each month take your annual profit
divide that by your total investment and
that will give you your return on
investment and i never buy a property
unless the return on investment is a
minimum of 15
per annum and then lastly you just got
to take action so if you're wanting to
get into vitalets pick up the phone
right now and start calling estate
agents telling them what you're wanting
to do and go out there and view some
houses if you get stuck along the way
message me on instagram and i'll help
all i can i am going to be running a one
day property investors crash course
where we're going to be finding live
property investments across the uk i'm
going to be talking about how to package
and sell deals different investment
alternatives and ultimately how to find
your patch and how to kill it in the
property market if you'd like to join me
at the property investors crash course i
will leave a free link spaces are
limited but they are free so get booked
on i'll leave a link in the description
if you want to see more videos like this
you can check them out right here come
down to the property investors crash
course i'll leave a link and don't
forget to subscribe for more videos i'll
see you next time
[Music]